I want to talk about the hashtag stay
home for Ozzy initiative that you
launched so simple but so important talk
to me about why it was important for you
to spread that message so a lot of
people I was seeing on my social media
at my window that weren't taking this
seriously that it's spring break they
don't want to ruin the party it's my
right as a human as a free-thinking
speaking America and I can do this and
that's just not how it is anymore and if
you don't have someone to stay home for
and you're a fan of my dad's music then
stay home for him you know my father has
COPD Parkinson's and he is really really
high-risk and they have told us how
serious this is
and I'm terrified and my mom is high
risk she's a cancer survivor
you know two-time cancer survivor chemo
everything and to know that you know not
just one but two of my parents at high
risk it's serious there's so many people
and there's so many reasons just to shut
up and stay home how is that so hard I
did have a cry yesterday because I miss
my parents and I'm really close with
them and I'm used to seeing them every
day and being with them every day and I
I just meant pretty much every day in
the last year with my dad and not being
able to see him is it's hard so later on
I'm gonna go over and we're gonna have a
cup of tea I'm gonna be outside if he's
gonna be inside have a little
conversation because I miss it when was
the last time you saw your parents you
obviously haven't seen them since this
all started right no he pushed forward
my father going to get his stem cell for
his Parkinson to go to Panama so the
last time I saw them was three and a
half weeks ago when I went to say bye
and give him a kiss before they took off
because we have a thing whenever they
fly together we all had to survive yeah
and we I I saw them I took my dad like a
cupcake or something and then that that
was it and if I would have known then
that that would probably be the last
time I get to hug him for like three or
four months I probably
would have gone to Panama with them can
we get a little health update on Ozzie
how's he doing today he's really good
he's frustrated he the stem cells is
working he's gotta go back again and do
a couple more treatments afterwards and
there's a huge improvement that we've
noticed he's like because now he's
feeling better
he's ready to go and get out of the
house and now he can't get out of the
house
ironing I mean you keep saying to me
he's like I've been on quarantine for
two years and now I'm feeling better and
the world is on quarantine I know God
timing is the worst your mom is such an
amazing caretaker how is she holding up
through all of this my mom and dad love
each other so much that if that's what
they have fun and they just do their own
little thing every day I call them and
they're giving me a list of things to
watch gossip my dad's been sending me
the most disgusting means thank you this
stuff and then it's probably my friend
Andrew that's sending it to him so I'm
just like okay good news or less and let
me try see if I can should find one
that's like okay
let me see this is this is a really good
one that he sent me this morning that
really made me laugh so I don't know if
you've been receiving a lot of mimics I
miss very well-endowed so oh that one oh
dear no but we're not doing his fist my
dad my dad sent me here we go
so have you watched Tiger King course
from my dad
leave it to Ozzy to have the best sense
of humor oh he will always and just my
favorite part about all of this is that
it took us named corn team to come
together together it's really lovely
the silver lining um I do want to ask
because you know we watched your GMA
interview as a family together and your
mom said that they had this trip planned
for April to go to Switzerland to meet
with a top doctor is that not happening
anymore what's the status bar I know
that's still happening Wow
and they fly privately so that isn't an
issue because I think they'll be able to
have the plane professionally cleaned
before he flies um but as far as I know
that's still happening I think if it is
for medical necessity they're allowing
you to still travel so that's plus and
do you have like really high hopes about
what this trip could possibly mean for
your dad's health
seeing after one treatment of stem-cell
what has happened and the progress that
he's made is like it's my last night Hey
look what have you seen what has been
the biggest difference she wants to get
up he wants to do things he must be a
part of the world again he's walking
better he's talking better his symptoms
are lessening he is building the muscle
strength back that he needs after his
spine surgery everything is starting to
fall into place now and it has given us
so much hope when we are very grateful
to the doctors that a lot of people are
watching the Osborn people have gone you
know you're watching it have you ever
watched old at the Sodor caught yourself
no like I was so insecure when we filmed
that and I mean I can watch it now and
and love it and think what I didn't like
you know I don't think I ever watch the
full episode you've never watched a full
episode of The Osbournes
who wants to relive a miserable time do
you know what I'm saying even though I
should let me remind that the first
season yeah second season when my mom
had cancer yes totally but we first fell
in love with the chaotic charm of your
family by watching that show so we thank
you for giving us that is there any
chance
you've returned to reality TV I feel
like you've got so much going on and
you're insecure about it whether the
deal actually happens and it goes
through it I've said this before this
year actually that this is the closest
we've ever come but keeps this parent
you know everything is on hold but this
month was meant to be the busiest month
for me and everything is gone okay we're
picking it up often I've got a lot of
questions okay my first question what is
this reality series that's possibly in
the works is it just a Kelly Osbourne
show or would it be the whole family
okay and what would it be
sort of like The Osbournes 2.0 like a
peek into your personal and your
professional lives I yeah of course it
would be so I mean we would never do
anything and not just show who we are of
course but is it like is there something
that's fundamentally different about it
Jack's like is Jack's grown we've grown
up you know there's another generation
of us and I think it's just show it's a
retrospective showing where we are now
this is where we are there what you know
I think people really want to see it I
don't as I say it's still up in the air
I don't know what's happening but what I
am and can confirm is that I am interval
very big talks about a return to TV with
a fashion show
Kelly sighting and I am the woman thing
that I was like okay it's giving me hope
I can work on this show while I'm in
here and I'm just warming and I pick
people that I want to work with and it's
that I am like still excited
[Music]